موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ان الفلسطينيه استشهد متاثرا
بجروح اصيب بها برصاص الاحتلال خلال
اقتحام مخيم عقب الجبر بمدينه اريحا ظهرا
امس
قالت مقرره الامم المتحده الخاصه بحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه انها ستحقق
في واقعه استخدام قوات الاحتلال لدروع
بشريه خلال اقتحامها مخيم عقبه جبر واكدت
للجزيره ان استخدام الدروع البشريه من
الممارسات الشائعه لدى قوات الاحتلال
وصف المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي الداعيه
لمحو قريه حواره بغير المسؤوله والمقززه
ودعا نتنياهو لادانتها
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه في التقرير اطلعت عليه الجزيره ان
نتائج تحليل عينات في منشاه فورد
الايرانيه اظهرت وجود جزيئات يورانيوم
عالي التخصيب بنسبه 83 و17 وهي النسبه
اللازمه لصنع قنبله نوويه
قالت المندوبه الامريكيه بالامم المتحده
ان ايران زادت تقسيب اليورانيوم منذ
انسحاب واشنطن من الاتفاق النووي في
المقابل اتهم وزير الخارجيه الايراني
واشنطن بانها غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار
شجاع بالعوده للاتفاق
بداوا وزراء خارجيه مجموعه العشرين
اجتماعهم اليوم بالعاصمه الهنديه
نيودلهيوا يلقي ملف اوكرانيا بظلاله على
اللقاء وقال مسؤولون امريكي واثقه من ان
الاجتماع سيدين واثقه من ان الاجتماع
سيدين الغزو الروسيه لاوكرانيا
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان القوات الروسيه احبطت محاولت هجوم
اوكرانيا مكثف بطائرات مسيره على منشات في
شبه جزيره القرم
هذا وتحتدم المعارك في جبهه باخموت
الاستراتيجيه بين القوات الاوكرانيه
وميليشيا فاجنر شرقيه اوكرانيا واخذت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه انها متمسكه
بالسعاده السيطره على المدينه وانها قامت
بارسال وحدات عسكريه اضافيه للدفاع عن
ضخمه
وقال موقع ريبار العسكري التابع لروسيا ان
ميليشيا فاجنر تقدمت في الجهه الشماليه
الغربيه لمدينه باخموت باتجاه اخر طرق
امدادات الجيش الاوكراني في المدينه
مررت لجنه شؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مشروع قرار يسمح للرئيس الامريكي
بحظر تطبيق تيك توك الصيني وتطبيقات اخرى
مملوكه لدول اجنبيه في الولايات المتحده
قال مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
الامريكيه في اي ان المكتبه بحث في اصل
جائحه فيروس كورونا وتوصل الى انه كان على
الارجح حادثا معمليا في مدينه وهان
الصينيه
المقابل شككت الخارجيه صينيه في مصداقيه
الاستنتاجات الامريكيه ووصفتها بانها
تلاعب سياسي
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء